- Welcome back, everybody.
We are here with Hannah
Waddingham and Reid Scott.
Give it up.
(audience cheering)
(Kelly clapping)
So that was a look at
Reid in the new fifth
and final season of The
Marvelous Mrs. Maisel.
You can see it on Prime Video.
So thank you so much for hosting our game.
You were killer.
- Thank you.
- You nailed it.
- I had a great time.
That was fun.
- And you gave personal stories.
I like it, I like it.
- Yeah, oh yeah.
I'm an open book.
- I get it, me too.
My mom doesn't love it.
(all three chuckling)
So did playing a host
on Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
did it help prepare for this job?
- For this?
- Yes, cause you killed it.
I just thought there
was some method there.
- That's why I took the job.
- It's all been leading to this.
- Yes, exactly.
I took the job on Mrs. Maisel
cause I knew that I was going
to play a host on...
- So you could prep.
Exactly, thank you.
- On give me a line.
- We like to set the bar.
- It was a great experience.
It really was.
I got to do research in a way
that I hadn't done before.
I always research whatever
character I'm doing a bit
to try to get inside the head...
- Yeah.
- Of that type of person.
But this was so specific.
And I grew up...
You know, my formative
years were the nineties,
- Me too.
- So the talk show scene between Conan
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And I think some of the
very best of David Letterman.
- Yeah, yeah.
- You know, Jay Leno
at his prime.
Those were my nights as a kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I revered them,
and I thought it was just
magical what hosts do.
And I never thought in a
million years that would ever
be anything I would pursue.
And then I got to play a bit of a host.
My character morphed into a host on Veep.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Where I played this total (beep).
- Which you can't bleep it
out if I spell that, right?
You can't bleep it out if I spell it.
- Which are fun characters to play, right?
That seems like
a more fun character.
- They're super fun.
- [Kelly] Yeah, yeah.
- Oh, it was the best.
And he played a host on
CBS and was really great
cause it was very satirical
how we sort of approached it.
And then when this came up on Maisel,
which is just an incredible
show, so beautifully written
and beautifully shot,
- [Kelly] For sure.
- they said they wanted to
sort of explore this guy,
kind of like a young Johnny Carson.
And I was like, oh wow,
that's really interesting
to me.
- Wow.
- It was just so fun to play in that space
but then also play the
duality of what it's like
when this guy who...
I'm making a career out of playing jerks,
which I don't know what that says.
(Kelly and Hannah laughing)
But what it's like when they yell cut.
What is he like when he goes home?
What is he like with his writing staff?
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- What is he like with Midge?
Who she comes on, they sort of,
they start to work
together in a bit of a way.
I don't want to give too much of it away,
but it was just great to sort
of feel those switches flip
in between the different personalities
that he sort of has to present:
one to the camera, one to the audience,
one to America, one to his staff.
- You just made acting sound really cool.
- Oh wow.
(Hannah and Reid laughing)
- Cause I love research.
- Yeah.
- And I love all the
development that goes into it.
- Yeah.
- [Kelly] That's exciting.
- But even if a character
is like, like you're saying,
not particularly nice or
they have this about them,
you have to fall in love
with all aspects of them...
- [Kelly] Mm hmm.
- To give them somebody else.
- [Reid] Exactly.
- I think.
- It's so exciting.
Yeah, you made it really, really exciting.
So wait...
- [Reid] Thank you.
We don't wanna be rude, but we had some
of Hannah's ice cream earlier.
So we wanted to offer you
some just sitting here.
- Oh my god.
Don't offer him the one I was going at.
(Reid and Kelly laughing)
- Oh, this is for me too?
- Just in case you wanted
to try it.
- Comes with an ice cream glove.
- Look, I'm Southern.
I know, right, like what?
Were we in the snow?
- It's very chic.
(Hannah and Kelly laughing)
- This is, oh my God.
- Yes.
- Wow.
- You're having...
[All Three] Biscuits with the boss.
- [Kelly] Just try it out. Just try it on.
You can leave it here if you'd want.
You don't have to...
- Oh, damn, that's good.
- It is good.
- Yeah, okay.
It's kind of like shortbread ice cream.
- It's like comfort food.
- Oh, it's the shortbread from the show.
- [All three] Yeah.
- Oh my God, that's really good.
- [Kelly] Yeah, that's
what it tastes like.
I never had it.
Okay.
- Isn't it gorgeous?
- So I heard that you now have...
I want you to have food in your mouth
when I ask this next
question. (all three laughing)
I heard that you now have a bad habit
when you're out with your kids.
What is it?
- Oh, oh, with my mouth.
- What's wrong with your mouth?
- That's not a sentence you hear everyday.
- Yeah, okay.
(everyone laughing)
- I swear a lot.
- Oh, me too.
- I have a filthy mouth.
- [Hannah] Oh God.
- Me too.
- I have a very filthy mouth.
- Look, I was a waitress.
- Good man.
- Thank you, right?
- Yeah, I just, yeah...
- I was a waitress.
- Look, people, they make you mad
and darn it doesn't cover it.
Yeah, like, yeah.
(Hannah laughing)
- Not in this town.
- Yeah, what is your...
Do you have a rule with your kids though?
- Well, it's morphed over the years.
- Okay.
- So my kids are almost
eight and just turned five.
- [Hannah] Ah.
- Like I tried the swear jar for a while.
- [Kelly] Oh my God.
My kids would be rich.
- That's gonna get full.
Yeah, yeah.
- It filled up so fast
that I was just using it to
like tip any delivery person
that came to the house.
This is not what the swear jar is for.
- No.
- Or it was like, you
know, tooth fairy money.
- Love it.
- Yeah.
- And so I realized, all
right, that's not gonna work.
It's not the deterrent that I need.
What really sort of brought
it home is I was driving
with my son, Conrad, and
someone ran out in front
of the car, and I
screamed like, oh my god,
you bleeping bleep.
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- And then everything was fine,
and I kept on driving, and
I hear this little voice
from the back go, Dada,
what's a bleeping bleep?
- Oh.
- And I'm like, oh...
- Don't tell Mommy.
- Yeah, don't tell Mom. It
was just something, you know.
Daddy got angry.
And he's like, oh, okay.
And then maybe two days later
the exact same thing happened again.
Like someone on a bike went right
in front of the car.
Like, oh my God.
The exact same expletives.
You bleeping bleep!
And then Conrad again is like, Dada,
there's those words again.
I'm like, yeah, son, yeah.
Really, really sorry about that.
(Hannah laughing)
Then maybe a week later,
I'm outside at the grill.
I'm having a good time.
I'm grilling up some food.
And our younger son was an infant.
And my wife comes out, and she's tired,
and she's bouncing the baby.
She's like, I just want you
to know what your son said.
He said, I want to kiss my baby brother.
I want to kiss that bleeping bleep.
(audience laughing)
(Hannah clapping and laughing)
- Oh, that's when you go,
where did he hear that?
- That's certainly not from me.
- That's crazy.
- Things they hear
at school these days.
- So I've had to rein
it back in a little bit.
And now my kids think it's a joke.
They're like, you're doing it again, Dad.
- Look, it colors a sentence.
- Look, I tell my kids that they can curse
when they pay their bills.
You have to earn being this trashy.
You have to earn it.
(everyone laughing)
I was like, you can't do it.
- It's good enough for Dolly.
- Like, do whatever you want.
- Be as class as you
want when you're older.
- [Reid] Yeah.
- [Hannah] That's brilliant.
- But like right now you can't do it.
- Yeah.
- Cause I'm like, I'm
not gonna just alter...
I'm not like, I don't curse
that much in front of them,
but like every now and then I'll slip up,
and then they'll be like, oh.
And I'm like, nah, nah, nah, nah, nah.
Don't even talk about it.
- My daughter has no
hope coming from theater.
She's got a right potty
mouth for a mother.
- I think that's the problem.
- Terrible.
- Yeah.
- But they need to see all sides of you.
- [Reid] Exactly.
- Yeah.
I'm just trying to show you all sides
of humanity.
- In moderation.
(Hannah laughing)
(Kelly laughing and clapping)
All right, we need another
commercial break everybody,
but you can see the final season
of The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
right now on Prime Video.